right i'm on less familiar ground here
so what i'm holding is the jabalani i
think that's how it's pronounced i hope
that's how it's pronounced official
match ball for the world cup which has
caused very many people and very many
players a great great deal of pain so i
feel a bit of a fraud talking about
football because i was the um
stereotypical nerd at school interested
in music interested in computer games
interesting computer programming it's a
new type of football ball football that
was
used for for the world cup in fact a
number of different clubs have been used
in it for example the german german
bundesliga
but it's the official ball of of the
world cup and the problem is very many
players are having great difficulty in
controlling it in fact some of them um
have said that it behaves as if the
supernatural is controlling it they
can't they really can't handle it in
simple terms a ball game through the air
you can imagine it as a ball of viewers
sorry
in simple terms of ball game prettier
you can imagine as a ball with the air
flowing smoothly around it but that's
really too simple because
the reality of the situation is that the
ball causes drag as it passes through
the air and so what you see is you see
the air spread out and instead of going
smoothly around it goes straight on and
then you get turbulence behind the ball
and that's that's drag what we're gonna
have to do to try and dig out and
understand just why it's so difficult to
control is get into what turns out to be
the really really difficult
area of fluid mechanics hydrodynamics
and how that relates to to objects
moving it
moving in a fluid the turbulence is
behind the ball in its past why is it
still affecting the ball ah well because
of conservation of momentum so what drag
there is on the ball the energy for that
and the momentum for that have to have
come out of the ball okay so
it's basically newton's laws of physics
that slow the ball down as it's passing
through the air the interesting thing
about this when you first look at it
it's not like a traditional football it
doesn't have the 20 hexagons the 12
pentagons which is the standard
buck minster ball which has been used
for quite some time it's it's got a much
more sort of smoother appearance much
more molded i guess than the standard
ball and also it has these rims and
these ridges all over it we've got an
object
luckily in this case it's quite it's
quite spherical and it's moving through
a fluid now generally think of fluids as
being liquids but the air is actually a
fluid
and
what forces are in this on this ball
well obviously there's the force
downwards due to gravity but there's
also it's moving through air if air
wasn't there if we didn't have air
resistance this would just go through we
didn't have any friction at all on the
ball it would just continue
for infinity but obviously we have air
and that ax that puts a drag force on
the ball
what's what's what we're seeing in this
world cup we've seen two things in this
world cup i think primarily apart from
swerve which we're not seeing in this
world cup um we're seeing the ball going
too far and i think you can attribute
that to two things firstly this ball
has been designed to have less drag so
the players aren't used to that and it's
catching them by surprise the ball is
traveling through the air it's going a
lot further and that's especially with
england you're seeing them overhitting
the ball a lot the key thing is just how
the ball moves through the air and
importantly how the air moves past the
ball so we've got two different regimes
really one of which is called laminar
flow and laminar flow is where you get
nice smooth stream lines going across
the ball the ball goes through through
the air and
what what you end up with a very very
smooth passage off the ball but in fact
for balls moving at any sort of velocity
comparable to that you um have in in a
game of football
soccer of that persuasion then it's in
fact what you get is turbulent flow the
other thing you're seeing is that this
ball is bouncy and we've just had a kick
around and it's like a powerball it's
unbelievable you touch it and it just
goes springing off and the reason for
that is because it's got a high
coefficient restitution right which
essentially means it's just a very
elastic ball if you like you can take a
ball you can drop it and the height that
it bounces back to the ratio of the
height that you drop it and the height
that it bounces back to its coefficient
restitution this ball bounces back about
70 percent of the way the important
thing is that as you as the the the ball
moves through the air is in this
turbulent flow regime you get little
eddies of of on vortices of of air and
what they do is that they change the the
pressure around the ball and something
called bernoulli's law important very
important law which basically relates
pressure and and speed so the higher the
speed the lower the pressure and so if
you if you have this ball moving through
the air you're getting these these
eddies uh these vortices set up you're
changing the velocity but you're also
changing the pressure and those things
are coupled together and so what you can
do if you if you change that turbulent
flow you play with that turbulent flow
then what you can do is you can adjust
the pressure on different on different
sides of the ball if you put spin on the
ball you can also adjust that pressure
difference and that is how you control
the ball that's how you move it make it
move different um
directions footballers aren't
traditionally the smartest people in the
world are you saying they understand
laminar and turbulently it's remarkable
how they i'm sure that they don't well
i'm sure that some of them might
understand but i'm sure that the
majority probably don't understand
laminar and turbulent flow pretty
certain i don't understand lamin on
turbulent flow but it's remark what is
remarkable is that that simply by
practice and through training
footballers have sort of embedded all
this physics knowledge by intuition and
can bend the ball as almost at will the
best can so this new ball the difficulty
is because it's been changed and because
it's been made more aerodynamic and in
fact it has been made more aerodynamic
and in fact loughborough university
which like nottingham is in the east
middle spent a lot of time and effort i
think six years really working on on
this ball but the difficulty is of
course is that the players then have to
take have to somehow take account of
this without knowing all the detailed
physics of course in terms of how this
thing flies and so that's that's you
have to unlearn basically your control
of the ball and and and re-learn a
completely different way of controlling
it moreover the working um they're
playing in a very different
environment in terms of atmospheric
pressure and that will also affect how
the ball plays how it will affect how
the the you have this crossover between
turbulent and laminar flow it will
affect how the ball spins all of which
depend on just how it's so simple it
seems simple but it's very important
it's very very tricky to analyze just
how the the air flows across the ball
it's these effects it's the lack of drag
it's the bounciness of the ball and to a
certain extent but really not very much
it's the altitude that they're playing
at on occasion because obviously at
higher altitude the air's thinner the
ball drags less okay so this is a really
simple i thought it was a really neat
demo that i saw on the saw on the
internet
and therefore i've nicked it i've stolen
it um so what we have here is we're just
going to show an effect called the
magnus effect which shows how simply by
putting spin on a ball you can control
how it actually moves through to the end
again what it's well i'm not going to go
into the details exactly how this works
but the important thing is that by
controlling the velocity the speed of
air at different positions of the ball
then you control the pressure and by
controlling the pressure then you can
get it to go up and go down and do very
many different things what you want to
really look out for is that as i as i
pull this and let release it you should
see the um
the ball move up in the air to get some
lift upwards due to the fact that it's
spinning so let's try it
yeah that didn't work too bad that was
really cool so what was happening to
what i did there was just by um wrapping
the elastic band around it and then
releasing what you do is you put spin on
that so this is traveling through the
air but there's also a layer of air
which is basically coupled to the um to
the cups and so as that's moving around
we've got the air coming it's going
against air here so on one side what you
have is that this copper layer is moving
with the airflow and sorry with the
airflow and the other side it's moving
against the airflow and what that does
is that creates a pressure difference
and so what you can do from a pressure
difference you create a greater pressure
here than here you lift it up